what I want to talk about is what is
maybe the least efficient way possible
to approximate the number pi that's not
a good sale it's not a good sell but
it's really interesting so I want to
talk about approximating PI in the
Mandelbrot set maybe it's best to do a
little bit of a reminder about what the
Mandelbrot set is so remember the
Mandelbrot set was this object that we
have in the complex plane so here are
the real numbers and here imaginary
numbers and the Mandelbrot set was a
collection of complex numbers so I'll
try and sort of draw a nice version of
this here and it's complicated right and
it was this collection of complex
numbers that have the property that when
we look at the function Z squared plus C
and we apply it to 0 so 0 plugged into
this function is C and then we do that
again with the output so C plugged into
this function is C squared plus C and so
on a number C is in the Mandelbrot set
exactly when when we do this process and
repeat and repeat and repeat the numbers
say smaller than or equal to 2 but today
I'm not too worried about complex
numbers I just want to talk about real
numbers and the Mandelbrot set does that
mean we're just talking about things
along the line exactly exactly and in
fact I'm just going to be interested in
what happens on this portion of the real
line here so one thing I should say
first is that this point this point is
called the cusp of the Mandelbrot set
and this point is exactly the value
where C is 1/4 that's the last point on
the real line in that direction that's
right that's on the Mandelbrot set and
pause out here somewhere presumably
mm-hmm
so pi pi is not in the mandible so high
is not in the Mandelbrot set that's
absolutely right and when I say that I'm
going to approximate Pi in the
Mandelbrot set I don't mean that I'm
going to approximate PI on this picture
here I mean that I'm going to cook up a
bunch of numbers that have to do with
the Mandelbrot set that approximate pi
so you're going to use the Mandelbrot
set as a tool as a tool to approximate
by exactly exactly and of course you
know looking at this you could say well
it looks like there's a circle in there
which indeed this is a circle inside of
the Mandelbrot set but I'm not going to
use that one that's that's a little too
straightforward way to get PI so here's
the idea
what
opens if we take a real number that's
larger than 1/4 so as you said it's not
in the Mandelbrot set right and what
that means so let's call this number say
well I've already used C but let's call
it C anyways whatever this number C is
when we start doing this process for
this number C we look at the function Z
squared plus C and we plug in zero and
we output C then we plug in the output
and we get C squared plus C then we plug
in that output and so on at some point
these numbers are going to be larger
than 2 right because that was our
restriction that you're not in the
Mandelbrot set if these numbers are
eventually larger than 2 okay so what
we're going to do is to each number C
we're going to associate this number say
n of C and this is equal to the number
of steps of iterating 0 under Z squared
plus C so exactly the process I was
describing before until we get something
larger than to any number after the cusp
yes is gonna is a killer it's gonna kill
the Mandelbrot set that's right it's
gonna kill it eventually gets big yeah
the thing you're interested in now is
how quickly that number will kill us
exactly exactly and this is something
that's like totally natural to be
interested in this is how people draw
pictures of the Mandelbrot set for
example is exactly counting these kinds
of steps so if we start with a real
number C that's larger than 2 then after
the first step of iteration here we get
C itself which is larger than 2 and so
we know after just one step that that
parameter cannot possibly be in the
amount of brought set so in that case NF
C is just equal to 1 and we have this
very small value of N and that applause
to Oh numbers above 2 that's right but
as you might imagine the closer you get
into the cusps the more steps it takes
to get larger than 2 right we're
starting with a smaller number here and
so it takes more steps to get there all
right so let's make this a little bit
precise we start with a number really
close to 1/4 say say C equals 1/4 plus
Epsilon where this is some very small
positive and real number
I was just after the cost that's right
you're just to the right of the cusp on
the real axis there and then we count
the number of steps it takes
to escape this is something you can do
and say you know Wolfram Alpha or sage
or whatever computer program you want to
use so if you draw a table of how this
number NFC depends as epsilon is coming
in and getting smaller and smaller we're
coming in towards the cusp with C you
can actually count just by iterating how
long does it take to have a number
that's larger than two so for example if
epsilon is 1 then C is 1 + I or sorry is
1 plus 1/4 which is 1.25 then n SC is
just 2 it only takes 2 steps to get
larger than 2 oh that's right on the
other hand if we take some much more
reasonable value of epsilon say like
1/100 and so C is 0.26 say then the
number of steps it takes to escape turns
out to be 30 actually and if we take
epsilon to be say even smaller and so C
is even closer to 1/4 then the value we
get in that case is 315 oh well it's a
low steps it's a lot of steps right but
we're really close to the cusps ear it
should take a lot of steps to escape and
if we take epsilon even smaller so that
C is even closer to the cusp we get
something even better even larger value
of NFC no but you can see something
suspicious happening here right everyone
can see it so so what's happening here
is that as long as you put the decimal
point in the right place and as you can
see I've changed my Epsilon sort of
regularly here so the decimal point kind
of moves regularly too as long as you
put the decimal point in the right place
these values and of C are actually
converging to PI that's cool yeah yeah
so you get these approximations of Pi
right ok 3.15 it's not such a good
approximation 3.14 is a little better it
turns out that the next one is something
like 3 1/4 1/4 which is even better and
so on and so this tremendously
inefficient method of taking some value
of C that's really close to the cusp of
the Mandelbrot set and iterating many
thousands of times
times until you get a number that's
larger than two will give you
approximate of pi
our thanks to audible.com for supporting
this numberphile episode at the time of
recording audibles boasting a hundred
and eighty thousand titles in its
collection of audio books and other
materials and that number is growing all
the time among them is the last man on
the moon by Eugene Cernan who obviously
was the last man to leave the moon
surface back in 1972 a great thing about
this audiobook is it's read by the
astronaut himself that's one of the
great things about books like this you
sometimes can literally hear the
author's voice in your head you can also
go to audible and hear a sample before
you buy make sure you like the sound of
the narrator's voice if you'd like to
try it go to audible.com slash
numberphile and when you sign up for a
30-day trial membership you'll get your
first audiobook for free and that one
could be the last man on the moon if it
takes your fancy use that slash
numberphile URL so audible know you came
from here and our thanks to them for
supporting numberphile also worth noting
that you know I came in here to the
Mandelbrot set along the real axis
towards the cusp right but you can do
the same trick and play the same game
with other points here